[Music]
top gun maverick proved to be nothing
less than a mega hit at the box office
as well as among critics and fans after
a period of nearly 36 years between the
first top gun film and the sequel the
franchise seemed fairly complete
nevertheless with box office takings of
over 1 billion us dollars it is no
surprise that discussions about a
possible sequel are ongoing allegedly
intensive talks are currently being held
with the actors involved as rooster
actor miles teller revealed in an
interview with entertainment weekly cruz
has already had initial talks with him
about a sequel no wonder after all
rooster is the mainstay of the second
part alongside main character maverick
still the decision is cruz's loan
although teller would be thrilled about
a sequel at present cruise is likely to
have plenty of work to do with mission
impossible which means that a potential
follow-up would require quite a bit of
waiting time the question is really
about what story would be told in top
gun 3 because despite the fact that the
story of the two top gun movies was
mostly straightforward one would have to
find a plausible reason to keep telling
the story either way we are eagerly
awaiting further news on top gun 3. have
you seen topcon maverick and if so can
you think of a reasonable sequel let us
know your suggestions in the comments
we have known that a fourth captain
america installment is in the works for
some time now and also that it will most
likely tie in with the mcu series the
falcon and the winter soldier now it has
also been revealed who will be directing
the superhero adventure and that person
is julius onna the 39 year old is not a
big name in hollywood so far but with
the production of the cloverfield
paradox he was at least able to gain a
foothold in a well-known franchise even
though the movie is seen by many as the
worst of the series behind the scenes
onna gets active support from the two
screenwriters malcolm spellman and delon
musan both of whom also pant the script
for the falcon and the winter soldier
the much hope for appearance of
ex-captain chris evans is however likely
to remain a pipe dream although he was
already contemplating a return to the
mcu those responsible can hardly detract
attention from their new captain america
sadly a release date has not been
announced as of yet but in view of the
early production phase we do not
anticipate its release before 2024
comic-con finally kicks off again next
week in san diego california after two
year paws hundreds of thousands of fans
are sure to make their way there again
the question is what can movie and
series fans expect at this year's
convention well here's a short and sweet
overview of the most important panels
that will be present this time around
let's start with disney phase 4 of the
mcu is well underway and marvel's panel
is bound to be big as a result with two
mcu movies already released namely
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness and thor love and thunder
there's only one more left black panther
wakanda forever this sequel has long
been awaited and in addition to an
appealing storyline must also attempt to
provide a proper tribute to the late
king t'challa actor chadwick boseman
since there are barely three and a half
months to go until the release on
november 11th 2022 it would be very odd
not to show a first trailer marvel is
unlikely to show the full black panther
package at comic-con however as the
equally important d23 expo will also be
waiting for some exciting footage at the
beginning of september further
information can be expected on the
upcoming she-hulk series especially
after the rather unusual trailer with
poo cgi we can be eager about what the
responsible parties have in store for us
last but not least an appearance of ryan
gosling at the disney panel is also a
possibility after many rumors suggesting
that gosling would play the marvel
character nova the actor denied this and
shared that he would gladly embody ghost
rider instead this would not only make
him nicholas cage's successor but it
would also clear the way for a ghost
rider in the mcu which seems quite
plausible thanks to the multiverse
likewise president comicon will be
paramount pictures here fans are
primarily expecting news about the
upcoming dungeons and dragons honor
among thieves the cast and filmmakers
will be attending the panel to reveal
exclusive information the cast is
certainly impressive chris pine michelle
rodriguez sophia lilies and hugh grant
all have roles in the fantasy adventure
film the pen and paper game which was
particularly popular in the 1980s is
known not only from stranger things but
also from three movie adaptions behind
the camera jonathan goldstein and john
francis dalia's directors and the
screenplay is by michael gillio the
official release date of the movie is
march 3rd 2023 and we are already
eagerly awaiting the first video footage
in the form of a teaser or trailer
there's some good news to announce from
warner brothers as well according to an
instagram post by dwayne johnson black
adam will be presented at comic con on
saturday we can potentially look forward
to his second trailer for the dc movie
however warner may also have some
surprising info on shazam too while in
recent weeks voices kept racing that
pretty much ruled out a presentation of
shazam
lately reports began to accumulate again
which claimed the opposite and indeed
shazam fury of the gods will get a panel
as well here too you can possibly expect
a first trailer more details will be
revealed next week so what are your
expectations for this year's comic con
and do you perhaps even attend the
events on site feel free to let us know
in the comments
rumors have been floating around for
quite some time about the new marvel
series echo in which daredevil star
charlie cox will finally make his serial
debut appearance in the mcu as the
hollywood reporter now informs not only
cox but also his fellow actor vincent
d'onofrio will be involved playing the
antagonist wilson fisk aka kingpin we
will also get to watch alaqua cox as
maya lopez and the lead role who already
performed sad role in the hawkeye series
like in the comic book original main
character maya lopez is a deaf woman who
can precisely copy the movements of her
fellow human beings besides she's an
expert martial artist the novrio also
has previously appeared in hawkeye's
kingpin although he was last seen in
front of the camera with charlie cox for
the daredevil series on netflix in 2018.
moreover rumors are currently spreading
that daredevil will set out to find a
former ally in echo that makes an mcu
debut for kristen ritter as jessica
jones seems likely as for the remaining
defenders luke cage and iron fist
there's no update yet we're hoping for
official information from disney soon
since the release date is still to be
announced fans have mixed feelings about
the upcoming the last of a series many
are happy that their favorite game will
finally get more content others are
rather critical of the video game
adaption and feed that it will hardly
live up to the original either way the
film production is still in full swing
recently the official shooting was
completed and the movie is now in the
post-production phase moreover there was
a brief update from hbo chief casey
boyce a few days ago who told the
hollywood reporter about the prospect of
a release in early 2023 regarding
further details about the story though
he remained silent all we know so far is
that the series will be strongly based
on the two of the last of us games as
well as the expansion left behind in the
leading roles we will see the
mandalorian star pedro pascal as joel
along with resistance and game of
thrones actress bella ramsey who said to
play ally we expect more news about the
last of a series in the near future and
also hope to see a first teaser in the
next few months
black mirror is certainly one of
netflix's heaviest shows as this series
regularly and relentlessly holds up a
mirror to its viewers in particular when
it comes to technology and the media the
special thing about it is that almost
every episode is more or less a
standalone show which means that the
actors change regularly so far for
example madman actor jon hamm the falcon
and the winter soldier star anthony
mackie or even occasional actress miley
cyrus could be seen in various roles the
new season likewise promises a lot of
celebrity talent which should please
many fans after a three-year waiting
time among the actors for example is
breaking bad star aaron paul who is
rumored to be featured in a sequel to
season 4's episode uses callister in
fact paul already appeared in the
episode at the very end as the voice of
captain cole thus it is all the more
likely that he will appear in a
potential follow-up in addition house of
cards actress kate mara deadpool 2
actress zazzy beast as well as top gun
maverick actor danny ramirez are also
part of the cast nothing is yet known
about the content of the sixth season
but series creator charlie brooker has
already stated that he does not rule out
sequels based on older black mirror
episodes when exactly black mirror
season 6 will be released on netflix is
not known so far
this was the news for this week if you
enjoyed watching this video we can
suggest even more quality content for
you on our channel besides a new
originals episode on all the secrets and
the easter eggs you might have missed in
pixar's lightyear you can also watch the
brand new trailer for the lord of the
rings the rings of
[Music]
power foreign
[Music]